in that negotiation do you
think about the value of human life is
there a Dollar figure is there how do
you uh enumerate not enumerate quantify
the value of human life yeah that's uh
it's like Beauty seeing yeah the
beholder
so that was the first lesson on any
hostage negotiation really any
negotiation like it doesn't matter what
it is to you matters what it is to the
other side one of the things especially
in your in your conversation I listen to
with that Andrew
um by the way you guys uh I I another
thing I really liked about that
conversation first of all I think the
world of him Andrew huberman yeah Andrew
Ewan and uh You released it on my
birthday I appreciate that that was a
nice birthday perfectly just for you
yeah nice job thank you
but uh empathy is in the eye of the
beholder uh in every negotiation whether
it's over car a house
collaboration in your company with the
bad guys how does the other side see it
now the nice thing about kidnapping for
ransom if there if there's an actual
Ransom demand it's an actual demand
is it's a mercenary's business they're
gonna take what they could get and they
tend to be really good
at figuring out how much money somebody
has so
and again I'll keep drawing business
analogies
you're looking for a job with an
employer
there's a market price of the job
and then there's what the employer can
pay you
now maybe the market price of the job
Market's 150 Grand employer can pay 120.
but it's a great job you know we're
talking about Elon a minute ago
like I'd work minimum wage to follow him
around yeah you know that would be worth
it what are the value other than the
dollars and how hard is it to get the
dollars and how quickly can you get to
them
those these are all things that the bad
guys are good and kidnapping are good at
figuring out so
the value of human life to them is going
to be what can they get a crazy thing in
the kidnap business
we used to get asked by FBI leadership
when is this going to be over
NES would be when the bad guys feel like
they've gotten everything they can now
dissecting that statement
you're talking about when they feel
like they got everything they can so the
key to kidnapping negotiations are the
feelings of the bad guys we're talking
about feelings kidnappers feelings
which drives everything doesn't matter
what human endeavor it is
so it's not a reason it's emotion
there's no such thing as reason